En Chine, on les appelle les 1 000 villes au même visage.
En tant qu'architecte en Chine,
je dois me demander comment je peux changer ça.
Un jour, je marchais dans la rue,
et j'ai vu des gens vendre des poissons.
Ils avaient mis les poissons dans un aquarium cubique.
Alors je me suis posé la même question :
pourquoi un espace cubique pour des poissons ?
Aiment-ils les espaces cubiques ?
(Rires)
Non, évidemment.
Peut-être que les espaces cubiques, que l'architecture cubique
est moins chère et plus facile à réaliser.
Alors, j'ai fait quelques recherches,
j'ai pris un appareil photo et j'ai essayé d'observer le comportement des poissons
dans cet espace cubique.
Finalement, j'ai découvert qu'ils n'étaient sans doute pas heureux.
Le cube n'était pas une maison parfaite pour eux,
j'ai donc décidé de leur concevoir un nouvel aquarium.
Je pense qu'il devrait être plus naturel,
que l'intérieur devrait être un espace plus fluide.
Des intérieurs plus complexes.
Je pense qu'ils doivent se sentir plus heureux dans cet espace,
mais je n'en saurai rien car ils ne me parlent pas.
(Rires)
Mais un an plus tard,
nous avons eu l'occasion de concevoir ce vrai bâtiment pour les humains.
En fait, ce sont deux tours
que nous avons construites à Mississauga, une ville à côté de Toronto.
Les gens les ont appelées les tours « Marilyn Monroe » –
(Rires)
à cause de leur courbure.
L'idée était de construire une tour,
une tour d'habitation de grande hauteur, qui ne soit pas une boîte.
Elle est plus inspirée par la nature,
avec la dynamique du vent et du soleil.
Après avoir terminé de dessiner la première tour,
on nous a dit :
« Pas besoin d'en dessiner une deuxième,
répétez seulement le même dessin
et on vous paiera deux fois. »
Mais j'ai répondu : « Impossible d'avoir deux Marilyn Monroe à cet endroit. »
La nature ne se répète jamais,
alors il y aura deux bâtiments qui peuvent danser l'un avec l'autre.
Je me pose donc cette question.
Pourquoi, dans une ville moderne,
pense-t-on l'architecture comme une machine ou une boîte ?
Je veux savoir comment les gens voyaient la nature auparavant.
En observant cette peinture chinoise traditionnelle,
j'ai découvert qu'ils mélangeaient souvent
d'une façon spectaculaire le naturel et l'artificiel, créé par l'homme,
pour créer ce décor sensible.
Donc, dans une ville moderne, ma question est la suivante :
« Y a-t-il un moyen de ne pas séparer les bâtiments et la nature,
mais de les combiner ? »
Nous avons donc construit un autre projet en Chine.
C'est un complexe résidentiel assez grand.
Et il est situé dans un très beau cadre naturel.
Pour être honnête, la première fois que j'ai visité ce site,
je l'ai trouvé magnifique.
Et j'ai failli refuser le projet
car on se sent comme un criminel de faire quelque chose là-bas.
Je ne veux pas devenir un criminel.
Mais ma deuxième pensée était que
si je ne le faisais pas,
ils y installeraient de toute façon des tours urbaines standard.
Et ce serait dommage.
J'ai donc décidé d'essayer.
Donc notre méthode a été
de s'inspirer de la silhouette des montagnes existantes
pour en traduire les lignes dans la forme du bâtiment.
Ces tours prennent donc les formes
et la géométrie de la nature.
Chaque bâtiment a une forme différente,
une taille différente, une hauteur différente.
Et ils deviennent une extension de la nature
où ils sont situés.
Et vous savez,
les gens pensent parfois qu'on utilise des ordinateurs
pour dessiner ce type d'architecture,
mais en fait, j'ai beaucoup recours au dessin à la main,
car j'aime son côté aléatoire.
Et il peut contenir toute une palette d'émotions
impossibles à réaliser sur ordinateur.
L'architecture, les humains et la nature peuvent coexister
comme sur cette photo où elles se marient bien.
En fait, l'homme sur la photo est un architecte de notre équipe.
Je pense qu'il profite de ce beau décor naturel
et qu'il se sent soulagé de ne pas être un criminel –
(Rires)
en fin de compte.
De retour en ville,
à Pékin, on nous a demandé de dessiner ces tours urbaines.
Et j'ai fait cette maquette.
C'est une maquette d'architecture,
qui ressemble à une petite montagne et à des petites vallées.
J'ai posé cette maquette sur mon bureau et je l'ai arrosée tous les jours.
Et des années plus tard, nous avons terminé ce bâtiment.
Vous pouvez voir comment mon croquis fait à la main
s'est transformé en un vrai bâtiment.
Les deux se ressemblent beaucoup.
On dirait une montagne noire.
Et voici où ce bâtiment se situe dans la ville.
Il se situe au bord de ce parc magnifique.
Il est différent, très différent des bâtiments environnants,
car les autres bâtiments cherchent à construire un mur autour de la nature.
Ce que nous essayons de faire ici,
c'est d'intégrer le bâtiment dans la nature,
afin de pouvoir étendre la nature de ce parc dans la ville.
C'était l'idée.
Un critique d'art chinois a peint ce tableau.
Il a placé notre bâtiment dans sa peinture.
Voyez-vous qu'il y a une petite montagne noire ?
Elle s'intègre très bien au tableau.
Cependant, dans la réalité,
notre projet a été remis en cause
car il a une allure différente de ce qui l'entoure.
On m'a demandé de modifier mon dessin,
que ce soit la couleur ou la forme,
pour que le bâtiment s'insère mieux dans son environnement.
Je me suis donc demandé
pourquoi il s'intégrait mieux à son environnement naturel traditionnel
qu'à la réalité ?
Il y a peut-être quelque chose qui ne va pas avec la réalité.
Quelque chose qui ne va pas avec l'environnement.
Tout au nord de la Chine,
nous avons également construit cet opéra.
L'opéra est situé à côté de la rivière,
dans un parc en zone humide.
Nous avons donc choisi d'intégrer ce bâtiment au paysage environnant
et de le fondre dans l'horizon.
Le bâtiment ressemble au sens propre à une montagne enneigée.
Les gens peuvent marcher sur le bâtiment.
Pendant la journée ou quand on n'y joue pas d'opéra,
les gens y viennent, ils peuvent profiter de la vue
et continuer leur ballade dans le parc
sur l'édifice.
Quand ils montent sur le toit,
ils trouvent un amphithéâtre avec le ciel pour cadre,
où ils peuvent chanter en direction du ciel.
A l'intérieur de l'opéra,
le foyer est baigné de lumière naturelle :
on peut apprécier cet espace mi-intérieur mi-extérieur
et on peut voir la magnifique vue sur ce qui l'entoure.
J'ai construit plusieurs montagnes,
et ici j'essaie de vous montrer
un bâtiment qui, je pense, ressemble à un nuage.
C'est le Lucas Museum of Narrative Arts
qui est en cours de construction à Los Angeles.
C'est un musée créé par Georges Lucas,
le créateur des films « Star Wars ».
Pourquoi un bâtiment qui ressemble à un nuage ?
Parce que je pense, j'imagine, que le nuage est mystérieux.
C'est la nature.
C'est surréel quand cet élément naturel se pose sur une ville.
Le nuage attise votre curiosité
et vous donne envie de l'explorer.
C'est ainsi que ce bâtiment a atterri sur Terre.
En élevant ce musée,
en le faisant flotter au-dessus du sol,
on peut libérer beaucoup de terrain et d'espace sous le bâtiment.
Et puis nous pouvons, en même temps,
créer ce jardin sur toit au-dessus du bâtiment
qu'on peut visiter et d'où on peut admirer la vue.
Ce musée sera achevé en 2022
et vous êtes tous invités à le visiter quand il sera terminé.
Et donc, après avoir construit toutes ces montagnes et tous ces nuages,
nous bâtissons désormais ces volcans
à nouveau en Chine.
Il s'agit en fait d'un immense parc sportif
comprenant quatre stades,
dont un stade de football avec 40 000 places à l'intérieur.
C'est donc un très grand projet.
Et vous voyez sur cette photo
qu'on peut à peine distinguer le bâtiment du paysage.
Le bâtiment devient donc un paysage.
Il devient même une œuvre de land art :
les gens peuvent se promener autour du bâtiment,
l'escalader
comme s'ils se baladaient dans un parc volcanique.
Cette représentation montre l'un des espaces sous ces volcans.
C'est en fait une piscine,
baignée par une lumière naturelle venant d'en haut.
Donc, ce que nous essayons de créer,
c'est un cadre de vie qui brouille la frontière
entre l'architecture et la nature.
L'architecture n'est plus une machine fonctionnelle à habiter.
Elle reflète également la nature qui nous entoure.
Elle reflète notre âme et notre esprit.
En tant qu'architecte, je ne pense pas
que nous devrions reproduire à l'avenir ces boîtes d'allumettes sans âme.
Je pense que ce que je recherche, c'est la possibilité
de créer un avenir
marqué par l'harmonie entre l'homme et la nature.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)